[Music]
hello everyone at Perry here still at
San Diego comic-con and we've got
another exclusive interview for you
right now I feel like I say this about
all of our interviews but I really do
mean it I'm especially excited about
this one because I watched the first two
episodes and mine mind blown I still
can't believe what you guys pulled off
I'm talking about the new series undone
so I do want to talk about the animation
process behind this but I'm curious what
sparked this specific story idea for you
guys okay what sparked this story well
Raphael and I worked together on Bojack
horseman he's a creator of that show
which is tremendous and I wrote an
episode called downer ending the first
season which was about Bojack going on
this drug trip and experiencing this
alternate reality of a life you could
have had and after that Raphael said
like let's do a show like that that's
the show yeah and we talked about some
of our own personal experiences and I
talked about some history of mental
illness in my family my grandmother had
schizophrenia and I've wondered about my
own mental well-being and what could
happen if that awakened in me and then
in my mid-30s I I had a kind of nervous
breakdown had some serious depression
and anxiety try to find ways to work
through it and then ended up finding
kind of in indigenous cultures and
shamanic cultures and ancient traditions
and that was what helped me find my way
out of it and then through studying
these and studying with different
shamans and healers found out that there
are all kinds of different cultural ways
of thinking about mental well-being and
mental health and that possibly having
visions or hearing voices or feeling
these deep feelings can be messages from
beyond messages from ancestors that can
be ways to help you find your right
track your right purpose in life and
actually a guiding hand potentially so
this idea of there are many perspectives
about what's happening to us and if we
can talk about those if we can open them
out if we can discuss and maybe we'll
feel less constricted by some sort of
collective unconscious and break that or
find a new way to explore it that answer
just reaffirmed that I've barely
scratched the surface of this story and
now I'm even more thrilled to be able to
dig in deeper and see more so that was
the story idea where it came from but
how about the idea
of doing a television series with
rotoscoping because never been done
before it's incredibly ambitious it is
an omission show we talked about that
yeah we kind of realized right because
it combines you know all of the the
stuff from live-action with all of the
stuff from animation there's really no
shortcuts you know it's not like you
just shoot a bunch of stuff and slap
like a snapchat filter on it like it
really I feel like you guys should
release an undone snapchat filters that
has already pitched I want it right we
you know we wanted a look for the show
that felt special we wanted to look for
the show that felt serious and real and
and grounded we wanted to you know sell
that the show takes place in the real
world these are real characters with
real relationships you know it's not a
sci-fi fantasy show even though it kind
of is maybe if you interpret it in that
way but we wanted it you know to feel
like yeah what would happen to you if
this happened to you if you were
presented with this mind splitting
experience of maybe everything you
thought about reality was not true and
you could go on an adventure but you're
not just you know neo or Dorothy you're
a real person with real stuff going on
in your life it's not so easy to be like
yeah let's go you know let's break apart
the entire foundation of my reality and
so we wanted an animation style that
felts grounded in that way but then also
the beauty of making it animation is
that when the more magical fantastical
stuff starts to happen it still feels
within that world it doesn't feel like
oh you know click the special effects
are starting now it still feels like
yeah we're still in this real world but
now it's a little looser the fluidity of
it yeah lends to the notion that you
know that feeling of what has happened
is this real are we in dreamlike state
now or are we still in the kitchen
are we still eating dinner
and I like to equate the the beauty of
this show I think because it's
rotoscoped because it's animated
you can broach more serious topics and I
like to equate it to like you know a
kidnapper with candy whoa
that's so pretty that candy and then
they got you and then we undo the very
fabric that is real about it I'm happy
to be traumatized by a show like this
you thought you were getting into a van
with a man with candy I'm safe I'm glad
I'm learning this lesson through this
show and we've already discussed so many
complexities here I'm curious what your
first impression was when they pitched
the show to you and how it differed from
what it turned out to be it didn't
differ from what it turned out to be at
all it didn't it didn't different you
didn't know was gonna be rotoscoped at
first did you I didn't know would be
rotoscoped at first but I read the
script and I was that was my first
introduction to this to the story and I
fell in love with it right away I mean
the writing is is genius
it's brilliant I've never read such
beautiful scripts in my life
and that's honest to god but when I came
in after putting myself on tape with
Linda and they came in and you pitched
me the show and I and you told me your
story your experience with mental
illness and and you guys talked about
the process and you talked about
rotoscope I I knew what you were going
for because I was such an avid Linklater
fan and I was and I watched waking life
on a loop in high school it was my Bible
it was it was the it was the the prelude
to this for me in my life because I even
as a teenager I was starting to question
the than the fabric of my reality the
nature of my own reality and my own
spirituality and what I believed and
constantly questioning everything and
that and that movie really gave me
an insight to into what you were talking
about all these years later so I had an
idea and it how did it differ it became
even more magnificent than my you know
idea there was a previous there was a
slight attested thing that you shot that
I saw that and I and I was completely
floored by it I loved it it's fine art
it really is and it has a level of
sophistication to it
the writing the way that it's animated
but it's also extremely funny so you
will genuinely be affected and be crying
at certain moments while also genuinely
belly laughing at the same time there'll
be a lot of fluids coming out of you a
lot of fools all right you can do with
that what you will
did you guys ever consider anybody else
but Rosa for that lead role because
after watching those two episodes that
part feels so specifically you not just
because it looks like you but there's
there's certain parts of that
character's personality and her sense of
humor that like one way or the other I
would have associated with you well as
soon as we saw her read we said that
song that's all I felt like she found
corners of the character that we didn't
even know existed and really flushed
and we're so lucky to have her in the
pardon and on the show and and she's her
acting is so incredible and so subtle
and so beautiful you know we talk a lot
in the editing of the show in the
animating of it that Rove is an actress
who has a face for rotoscope e which
sounds like a backhanded compliment but
it actually means that she's just
incredibly subtle and expressive in a
way that just it's a dream for the
animators to kind of capture that
subtlety and find those micro
expressions it's it's creates a really
beautiful
thank you yeah and she talked about the
writing but really her performance
elevates the piece we have so many
gorgeous collaborators like Rosa who
really made the piece better and better
with their artistic input and a funny
little antidote is that our director
hiss Co he'll sing whose artist who sees
an oil painter and an animator and he
did these preliminary drawings of Alma
to help sell the show and when he saw
roses video her her audition
he said she looks just like the all not
that I drew this is uncanny
wasn't I I as in that strange yeah there
is a fair amount of serendipity here
there's a there's a fair amount of magic
that I think that we all gloss over in
our day-to-day lives or just kind of
pass it off as being a coincidence but I
think there is a fair amount of magic
when I when I read that script it spoke
right to me it's but write to me
immediately it was like Ruth like she
was there she was in me there were many
parallels to the character that I
already shared but it came at a time
that was ready to investigate these
things that I that I wanted to that I
had already done a similar process of
being animated and similar in some ways
in some ways but but this was a
completely different undertaking and
honestly this was much more spiritually
challenging emotionally challenging
physically challenging mentally
challenging and and I'm so grateful I'm
so grateful
that you made this show we're grateful
that you're doing the show with us
because I remember when you came in you
said my reps and I have just decided I'm
just gonna do movies now yeah but I read
this and I want to do this yeah yeah oh
no in the vein of being grateful can I
just say Collider has always always
Collider has always supported your girl
Rosa so do you under coming this fall
it's easy to promise you that that won't
happen because again I have seen two
episodes you do not want to miss this
seriously thank you guys so much for
your time today I have a million and one
questions about the rotoscoping process
that hopefully we can revisit this as a
movie back there's gonna be more time in
the future yeah alright guys we have to
say goodbye thank you so much for your
time and a lighter thanks to everybody
out there watching this video right now
as always do not forget to like and
share it and guess what we're gonna have
more comic-con 2019 interviews coming to
the channel real soon